new in theaters this weekend Gretel and
Hansel and the rhythm section what will
you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
please make your queries
I'm called Gretel and this rough one
here is my brother Hansel in an
exceedingly creepy retelling of the
original Gretel in Hansel sees a brother
and sister stumble across a house too
good to be true
that is indeed housing an evil witch and
many dark secrets
looks like Beverly from it escaped
Pennywise only to stumble across another
monster this movie is for you if a
horror movie sounds good to you you like
creepy movies that keep it to a pg-13
rating or if your real one and you're
gonna see this movie at one of those
theaters where you have dinner and watch
a movie almost my family three years ago
they would kill nothing find people who
did this I'll kill every last one of
them when a woman loses her family in a
plane crash her life spirals downward
but she soon learns that the crash
wasn't a mistake
and she decides to set off seeking a
revenge at any cost this movies for you
if an action movie is what you seek this
weekend you're a fan of Blake Lively or
if you're not a fan of Blake Lively
yes that is your weekend ticket what
will you see and check back next week
for Harley Quinn and her new crew